and I'm gonna help you remember how to
do this now I've said here's a function
right we're gonna graph it on the y-axis
and the x-axis the first instant you
should have when you see something like
this you know you're gonna graph it is
you should be wanting to factorize this
and I've deliberately given you
something which is nice and easy the
factorization is X plus 2 X plus 3 okay
you've got to be able to do that
reflexively this is that part of the
math syllabus we call fluency right just
like you're fluent in language you're
like I don't need to look up words in a
dictionary to say sentences that make
sense you should be able to do that
without thinking ok especially for an
easy one like that I did it on purpose
okay now what are you going to read off
when you see X plus 2 X plus 3 what
information does that give you ok so you
could expand it back if you wanted but I
want something more important ok x
equals negative 2 and x equals negative
3 what what are those things
they're the X into this thank very much
so I'm gonna go 1 2 3 so I'm putting in
a couple of markers there right that's
negative 2 data Street that's where my
intercepts are going to be okay
now under some circumstances I'll just
say cool it's not drawing graph okay but
I'm not gonna do that because I know if
I draw a graph right now it may or may
not go through the other things that I
want on my graph and I want to be
reasonably accurate right so I've got X
intercepts do I have any other
intercepts on you to worry about or y
intercepts right so where can I read
that off it's just 6 there is we had a
nice little discussion about this when
we were going back to this earlier y
equals 6
that's gonna be my intercept I'm gonna
place it around there so I'm actually
gonna mark these in negative 2 3 ok
would you be content right now to say 1
2 3 I can go through all those points
you can probably do it reasonably well
but I have specifically asked you to put
the vertex in and we know how to find
this right you can do this in one of two
ways you could say the vertex lies on
the axis of symmetry right and the axis
of symmetry has this equation x equals
minus B on 2a so you could do that you
could get a and B out of there and you
can get an equation okay oh by the way
quick question why doesn't the axis of
symmetry have sing in it you know how
it's ax squared plus BX plus C bless you
why tires the axis of symmetry it just
seems to ignore see what's up with that
yeah what do you think you meant C is
like Y C okay all right so C is the
y-intercept but so what like why why
would that the C attaching to this why
would that mean it has nothing to do
with this now let's think about this
right the axis of symmetry it's a
horizontal thing isn't it like it's wall
for this kind of power parabola here
we're gonna look later on at parabolas
that are actually sideways so that right
but for this right the axis of symmetry
will be a vertical line in fact I'm even
gonna go ahead and put it on the graph
can you do it with me
when you put this in you're going to get
negative two and a half it's right
between these two intercepts right so
let's just put it in there like so
x equals negative two and a half now
that C write that plus six what it does
if you think back to when we were
transforming graphs right that plus C
the six in this case what it does is it
moves the graph up or down do you agree
with that like it slides it up six units
or down six units or whatever okay now
just have a look at this axis of
symmetry what would it look like how
different will it look this is not a
trick question I promise
how different would it look if I moved
this axis of symmetry up six units how
different would it look to what it looks
like then if I move this guy there's a
ruler know that here it is right for my
face there is a really here so here's my
vertical line
he is my axis of symmetry I'm gonna move
it up six units thing okay okay we go
mm-hmm how difference is a look and it
doesn't look any different because it's
just a vertical line if you move a
vertical line vertically it's it's still
the same line right so that's why this
is what we would say independent of C
right doesn't matter how far you be this
up or down okay what are you gonna do
with that uh x equals negative two and a
half how will you use it to find the
vertex the vertex will be on this line
so I'm gonna take this value and where
am I gonna put it when I'm doing it very
good I'm gonna substitute into one of
these they're both the same thing right
has anyone actually got this value
already ah interesting
all right so Russ is asking about this
guy up here right now can I just get a
show of heads who took this value and
put it into X square plus 5x plus 6 who
did that in your code yeah okay no
problems so we find some of you did not
I don't know if that's just because you
haven't got your calculator yet you can
put x equals negative two and a half
into either of these because what the
factorization is saying is that the same
thing right just different ways to write
it this is easier to see the X
intercepts actually I'm going to argue
it's also easier to calculate the Y
values the vertex through this because
look at it right if I put in negative
two and a half into here what's negative
2 and 1/2 plus 2 negative 1/2 right I'm
just gonna write this down here so it's
not my right negative 1/2 what about
negative 2 and 1/2 plus 3
that's a half that's easy to do I don't
need a calculator for that do I that's
negative 1/4 just like a sunset okay
hopefully you got that confirmed if you
put that into your calculator okay
all right now negative 1/4 that's not
very far off the x-axis is it it's low
but it's not much lower than that axis I
have to be careful cuz see this value of
6 here that I put on the y-axis it means
I actually have a scale that's implied
here so if I went and said okay if that
is 6 on your graph wherever you put 6
right if you go half way down that's 3
right it should be 3 if I keep going now
and break that into two and one
I want my x equals negative 1/4 to be
consistent with that scale right so if
that's X's sorry y because positive 1
there's y equals negative 1 and I want
to make sure negative 1/4 is about a
water the way down so it's not fire at
all do you see that so maybe if you just
like reflexively drew this it'd be much
lower so you've got to be careful here
you want to make sure it's all
consistent bless you so I'm going to put
it about there not very low at all okay
now just one last thing we're gonna draw
this now that vertex right do you
remember I gave it an extra name a
special name which is actually leaning
forward to when we make calculus it's a
long name starts with s 0 Nova stay
stationary point I call it a stationary
point which is a word from calculus if
you don't remember it don't worry it
will come up later but what that means
is down here it's kind of flat basically
so actually a trick that I use is when
I'm actually graphing this thing if I
know at the vertex I'm gonna have this
spot here
I actually draw a horizontal line there
I literally draw a horizontal line
because I don't want to I want to avoid
the thing where I'm drawing I'm drawing
I'm drawing right and then I'm like oh
no I'm at the bottom and then you kind
of have to like sharply come up and your
graph cut it looks funny it shouldn't do
that it should be nice and flat kind of
like a rounded at the bottom so that's
why I put that horizontal line there
so that when I draw this it's going to
be reasonably accurate ok now I'm going
to try and fit into the rest of this so
it's going to come up through that
intercept there and I've got to get up
to the 6 so there we go
I'm pretty happy with that it's not my
most beautiful work but it goes through
all of the points that I need and it's
got the general shape I'm happy